if you start going through this bill i
just read this piece today by isaac
shore in national review
there's a provision in there for federal
employees to be given
21 000 additional
if their children have had to do school
from home and that's been a hardship for
them
it's outrageous
right so as someone that worked in the
government and had to like manage
messaging and stuff when they come up
with these numbers okay we want 600
billion we want 1.9
trillion it's like doesn't it all kind
of feel
made up like that like where are these
numbers really coming from who's really
paying for it like that there's never a
cost there's never a cost to be like i'm
the guy that wants to cut some stuff so
you'd never do it because or there's no
there's never a benefit
in other words like i'm gonna cut some
stuff no one's gonna really give you
credit people just want more and more
and more and more
yeah so um you imagine that ron clayne
would say
we can do 1.9 trillion dollars but don't
you
dare think about going to two trillion
dollars because two trillion dollars
into the year is like that's why things
cost 9.99 at the store
you know that's they don't cost 10
because you'd be like well i'm not going
to pay 10
but 9.99 that sounds that's reasonable
um
in some and i think what the democrats
think when you the more you look at this
bill
there's very little little that's
specific for covet relief and they have
a particular philosophy and they're
sticking to it they think that the
stimulus bill that obama passed in 2009
was way too small
and that it did not do enough to help
the economy and that was one of the
reasons that they say
that the economy stalled they don't talk
about the regulations that they put on
businesses
all the things that they were trying to
do to engineer
the economy as the problem they think
that not passing more stimulus in 2009
was what hurt obama
and ron klain came into this saying that
we are not going to go too small that
the danger of
going too small is worse than the risk
of spending too much that's that's our
position
but if you start going through this bill
i just read this piece today by isaac
shore in national review
there's a provision in there for federal
employees to be given
21 000 additional
if their children have had to do school
from home and that's been a hardship for
them
it's outrageous you check that out i
mean there's the swamp
i think that's what we call the swamp is
that what we call this that is that is
so much the swamp isaac shore national
review check that one out
there's the things like the 100 million
dollars for
the bridge that chuck schumer wants in
canada there's the
100 million dollars that nancy pelosi
wants for
that transportation project from san
francisco out to
silicon valley where i thought everybody
was working from home now so why do we
need that
um actually they've all moved to miami
that's the real truth
right so that they could save on on
taxes
um there is so much in this bill that
has
nothing to do with covet relief and
what what think back to what happened
what was born out of the stimulus
package in 2009
the tea party you know they they
got the grassroots attention i have a
feeling that
this could be the same thing now i also
absolutely believe that there are many
people who have suffered
in this pandemic through no fault of
their own a lot of restaurant owners
waitresses um people that worked in the
hospitality and we could target specific
money to them
but you go through this and it is a big
wish list and part of the thing is that
republicans
um disagreeing amongst each other that's
normal it's going to happen
but that is like catnip for reporters
they're always going to report on that
they don't do it as much with the
democrats though they have
lots of differences amongst themselves
but republicans
have not really been able to figure out
a way to drive a message about this bill
and i don't know how you feel about this
dave but the the
the legislation as written has a 73
approval rating
across the country well i think to me
it's just that people don't know
what's in anything it's sort of what
you're saying and it's like oh you see a
high number so you're like oh
i kind of don't know where the money
comes from but i guess it doesn't come
from me and they'll just take it from
somewhere and then if it's a high number
that means i'll get more so no
politician
ever wants to be the one well i guess
there's probably one guy that kind of
does it every now and again which is
rand paul
is the one guy that's like oh maybe we
can't pay for all of this or maybe we
shouldn't be doing all this stuff
and that's just sort of how politics
works and then you sound mean
uh right then you're mean and cold
that's right yeah then and then and
we're about to see like right after this
um they're going to pass a
infrastructure bill too
and it will be probably four trillion
dollars
do you think that the democrats
basically fundamentally believe that you
at this point that you can just print
money endlessly because i i just have
come to that like they don't there's no
economic principle for any of this and
by the way it's not like the republicans
are so great they
you know trump cut taxes and also the
budget exploded too so like
they're all guilty but i think more
fundamentally it seems the democrats
believe that you can just print print
print
print money which also makes their
position on taxes a little weird because
then why would you always be raising
taxes on the rich
unless it's purely to punish them right
if you if you can just print money
in an unlimited supply then why do you
have to punish people too well i guess
if you if you just need an enemy
to point that but do you think that or
is that all of government at this point
which is just ah we'll just make up
numbers and just keep printing and
you know we'll go as we'll go as far as
we can until the end until we ride right
off the cliff well not only that but i
don't think that you have many people in
business telling them not to
yeah right so so who's who's standing
a thwart saying no um you know a few
congressmen and people on fox news it's
probably not gonna they're not gonna cut
it
um and republicans are also guilty but
look the law of economics
it's called law for a reason um the laws
of economics haven't changed
um i do i think the democrats think they
can
print money but also i think that they
think they can tax their way out of this
problem
but i'll tell you one thing about that
if you go back to um obama era
and when the bush tax cuts were going to
expire
they actually kept them because
economically they knew that
that would actually hurt economic growth
even more um
raising taxes at that time so i don't
know how they're going to
raise all this money i mean hope hope is
not a plan
yeah and that you don't want your
accountant to be hopeful
right um and that's what we're dealing
with right now
right so before we get to the book i
want to ask you a little bit about uh
you've had a couple changes kind of in
your in your day-to-day
shifting around your schedule and you're
doing like 87
shows and all kinds of stuff but i also
want to ask you about um
fox and kind of what's going on over
there because i still hear this a lot
when i go on fox like there's a certain
amount of people that are just sort of
pissed at fox that a year ago
were were not pissed at fox do you hear
any of that do you think any of the
criticisms
anymore it's legit not so much anymore
no i mean
obviously i heard a lot about that you
know right after the election but
i think now that the new administration
is underway and there's a lot of new
programming
fresh programming here at fox um it's
kind of some exciting
programming uh of course you know in
that seven o'clock hour
rotating host right now um lawrence
jones was uh hosting this week
yeah did a great job last night trey
gowdy has been great um
uh rachel campos duffy was good katie
pavlich i was like wow we have a lot of
talent here and so that's great
my job changed and that um i was doing
the daily briefing with dana perrino at
two o'clock which i loved you know when
you could come on as a guest
and then the five which i've done for
nearly 10 years now can you believe it
10 years in july that's crazy that's
absolutely crazy
yeah because jasper's nine that's always
keep track so that we started in july of
2011.
um so in december just as i'm finishing
up this book
just as the elections you know sort of
behind us um
i think i'll have a relaxing time get
covered behind us with these vaccines
and they get a call saying we have an
idea like oh
i love ideas but your idea and it was
for me to no longer do
america's excuse me the daily briefing
but to
co-anchor america's newsroom with bill
hemmer from nine to 11 in the morning
i was shocked pleasantly so
um i love bill hemmer i actually am one
of those annoying people that loves
mornings
um i like doing that news first
of the day and i have to so we've been
doing it since january 18th and it has
been
such a joy i love it
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell